the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what sob ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight predictions video as I'm sure most
of you know by now there have been many
different events throughout the course
of Game of Thrones that I said a big
impact or not only the characters within
the show but also us as an audience now
I should say this video might seem like
a breakdown of the first episode but I
don't want to go over every single
possible scene in today's video I want
to go over some of the big events that
we could see as of right now I can't
predict every single scene that will
happen next season but if you keep in
mind how season 7 ended along with the
direction the show has been heading in I
think we can take a good guess at what
some of the big events will be in the
final season of Game of Thrones now I do
want to clarify one thing before we go
any further when I'm referring to a big
event that doesn't necessarily mean it
has to involve any action sequences at
least not in my opinion there have been
a number of different events that did
not involve any action that had a big
impact on the story and the characters
just to give you a few examples
when bran Stark was pushed out of the
tower window when King Joffrey was
poisoned at his own wedding and when Jon
Snow was resurrected by Melisandre I
would not consider those to be action
scenes but each of them did have a very
big impact on the television show and
even us as an audience so with that in
mind let's move on to my predictions for
the final season you might have heard me
talk about some of these things in
various videos before but this is my
first time putting all of them together
in the same video let's start off with
the very first episode of the a season
we have heard from a number of different
sources that the opening scene of the
final season will take place in and
around Winterfell the Home House Stark
this will most likely involve the
arrival of Jon Snow Daenerys Targaryen
and their respective parties this is
interesting because the very first scene
has a lot of potential to be a big event
for many different reasons first let's
get the reunions out of the way because
my god there will be a lot of them in
the opening episode this scene was
already teased a few months ago when HBO
released a very short
clip a Jon Snow and songs of stark
reuniting and Winterfell together now I
would consider this to be a big event
because not only will this be a very
powerful scene on an emotional level but
most other reunions will lead to some of
these characters doing some great things
together in the future we have already
seen Jon Snow reunite with sons at
Castle black but what makes the scene so
special was the fact that Jon Snow will
be reuniting with Arya Stark and brain
stark two characters he hasn't seen
since the first season of the show I'm
already expecting the reunion between
Jon and Arya to be very emotional but
when Jon reunites what bran this will
completely change everything not only
does bran stark have a major secret to
tell Jon Snow but these two characters
working together will most likely lead
to the downfall of Westeros his biggest
threat which is the night king as I've
said in some of my previous videos
before Jon Snow and bran stark have the
closest connection to the night king I
think it's safe to say that even the
night king might look at Jon and brain
as potentially his biggest threat as
well we have seen glimpses of this in
previous seasons the night King not only
entered brain Starks vision but he was
also able to reach out and grab him by
the arm and of course we cannot forget
the two epics tear downs between Jon
Snow and the night king the first time
it happened was at hardhome then we saw
it happen again when Jon went beyond the
wall to capture a wight this is
obviously leading to a final
confrontation between the members of
House Stark which if you've seen some of
my other videos then you would know that
I think the night king is also a member
from House Stark
we know that Jon Snow wants to stop the
night king and brain Stark wants to stop
the night king as well so when Jon Snow
and bran reunite they will begin to
devise their plan of stopping him for
good
we know that brain can go inside of the
weirwood net to hopefully find out more
information about the night king like
where he wants to go what he ultimately
wants and hopefully how to stop him once
bran finds out all the information he
can tell Jon what to do then Jon can
apply that knowledge on the battlefield
so even though I'm dying to see the
reunion between Arya Stark and Jon Snow
I believe one of the reunions that will
have the biggest impact on the story is
when Jon and Brandon Knight next season
also like I said a minute ago brain
still has a very big secret to reveal to
Jon as well this also has the potential
to completely change everything because
we know how
everyone will react to that news there
is a very good chance that this could
piss a lot of people off for obvious
reasons one reason is because for years
Daenerys has believed that she is the
rightful queen of the Seven Kingdoms
ever since her brother died in the first
season Daenerys has said that she was
next in line to take the Iron Throne but
now we know that is not true
thanks to Samwell Tarly Gilly and bran
Stark we know that John is the son of
Lyanna stark and rhaegar targaryen since
Rhaegar and Lyanna were married that
makes Jon Snow a legitimized Targaryen
and next in line for the Iron Throne
that revelation can make Daenerys very
angry now there is always a chance that
Jon could step aside for Daenerys but
until that happens we don't know how
that's gonna play out not to mention we
also have to consider how all of John's
bannermen react to that news we already
know there is no love for the Targaryen
zat the north in fact some of John's
biggest supporters already voiced that
opinion before he left to go greet with
Daenerys they told John that a Targaryen
cannot be trusted
so what are they gonna do when they find
out that John is the child of Rhaegar
Targaryen
will they abandon his cause and flee
back to their homelands or could one of
them even try to kill John now I know
that would be a drastic decision but it
would not be the first time John was
stabbed by one of his own men these are
just some of the reasons why brain stark
has to be very careful with the way that
he reveals that information he might
want to pull John aside and tell him
that in private that way John can break
the news after when and if they defeat
the night king he doesn't want to risk
losing all of his allies before the main
event begins now I'm pretty sure I've
said this before
but I don't think John's parentage gets
revealed in the first episode I don't
know if bran will tell John right away
and we also know how this story treats
its fans
we never get everything all at once I
believe their first conversation could
be about bran stark being the new
three-eyed raven and some of the things
that he has seen that involved the night
came this is obviously the most pressing
issue at the moment especially when you
consider that John doesn't even know the
night King has knocked down the wall yet
in my opinion that should be the very
first thing that brain says to John that
way they can start to prepare the castle
and their soldiers for battle they need
to start making weapons ASAP and the
castle needs to be fitted for some
defensive weapons as well let's move on
though because
have a lot of other things to cover so I
talked about John finally reuniting with
Arya and bran but John will have another
reunion that should have a very big
impact on the story which is when Jon
reunites with Samwell Tarly these two
characters haven't seen each other since
season five and in fact Sam just
happened to have left right before John
was murdered hopefully we get to see
them discuss that for at least a few
moments because I would like to know
what Sam thinks about John getting
resurrected but the reason why I think
the reunion has a lot of potential is
because of some of the things that
Samwell Tarly currently possesses as we
all know Samwell has his family's
ancestral Valyrian steel sword hearts
Bane but Sam also has all those old as
books and documents he took from the
Citadel we don't know exactly what's
inside of them yet but they are
obviously very significant otherwise
they would have never shown Sam taking
those things out of acid now we do know
that Sam was trying to find some of the
answers to stopping the White Walkers
but we also know one of those books
contained what looked like to be the
phases or cycles of the Moon this could
lead us to finding out why the seasons
are so unpredictable in Westeros george
RR martin did say that we would
eventually find out why the winters last
so long and by the looks of it the
television show might reveal that
information as well it most likely
relates to the White Walkers in some way
and when or if they are defeated
I imagine the seasons will go back to
normal but that's just a guess anyway
Samwell Tarly will also play a very big
role in defeating the night king he
might not be the one to swing the sword
but as I've said before he will assist
bran in determining where to look inside
of the weirwood net to find the answers
we have already seen these two
characters working together in this
season 7 finale and we will continue to
see them work together throughout the
remainder of the show Samwell Tarly
should be able to find some of the info
in those books then he can tell bran
where to look inside the weirwood net
then Brian can tell John what to do on
the battlefield these three characters
will complement each other's abilities
next season with their powers combined
they are Captain Planet now let's move
on to some of the other characters in
John's party because there are a few
other reunions that could lead on to
something big in the upcoming episodes
let's start off with ginjury as we all
know ginjuries main job is to make
weapons for the upcoming battle against
the night king
when Davos went and found Gendry he told
ginjury they needed him in Winterfell to
work in the forges which ginjury did
agree to do when Davis took Ken jury to
meet John he was supposed to keep his
mouth shut and just go straight to
Winterfell to get started right away but
gander he could not resist telling John
who he was which did lead Gantry to go
and beyond the wall with John thankfully
ginjury was able to survive that mission
and now he should be on his way to
Winterfell as well now this is where I
want to throw you a little curveball
because everyone knows who Genji should
reunite with the next season but I want
to discuss another possibility first in
the books
Gendry has a very interesting encounter
with Brienne of Tarth now they might not
do any of this in this show but I want
to briefly touch on it just in case that
they do when ginjury and Brienne meet in
the books
Brienne can't help but think how much
Genji looks like Renly which we all know
Brian loved Renly we could get a scene
where Brienne talks to Gendry about this
or at the very least Brienne could see
ginjury from across the courtyard and
she might do a double-take noticing how
familiar he looks but that's not the
main reason why I wanted to talk about
this some of you might not actually know
this if you haven't read the books but
Gunn jury saves brianne's life I did
read the chapter in one of my videos but
some of you might not have seen that
video in the books
Brienne gets into a vicious fight with
the character known as biter he was one
of the men that was locked up with Jack
in a gar well during their fight bringen
gets her ass kicked pretty damn bad
biter ends up breaking some of her bones
he gives her a serious concussion and he
also bites off a big piece of her cheek
during the fight as Brianna's starting
to lose consciousness
bihter climbs on top of her and he has
moments away from killing her by Geng
jury comes up from behind him and he
shoves a spear through the back of his
head the spear that Kendra uses actually
goes right through his skull and it
pokes out through his mouth it makes it
almost look like he has a big red tongue
with a very sharp edge to it it actually
looks very similar to what Jon Snow did
to Carl tanner
now obviously we will not see Brienne
and biter fight next season however I
can't help but wonder if the show will
try to include a scene where again jury
does save burying at some point like
perhaps during the battle against the
army of the Dead I think that would be a
nice little nod to the books
and it would also give ginjury something
else to do besides just making weapons
but anyway sorry to go off on that
little tangent but I just wanted to
throw that out there like I said another
highly anticipated reunion is that of
Arya Stark and ginjury fans have been
waiting for this ever since they parted
ways in the third season but we've had
to wait until the final season for it to
finally happen obviously this would be a
very emotional reunion but the main
reason why I want to talk about this is
because it could be setting up something
for later if you've been a subscriber of
my channel since day one then you would
know that I have been on aurilla and
Gendry supporter for many many years now
just because they reunite doesn't mean
that they will settle down together at
the end but there is always that chance
then this could plant a seed that could
grow into something much larger in the
later episodes
perhaps Ken jury is the part of Arya's
endgame or maybe even Songz's either way
this would fit into Robert Baratheon's
wishes of finally uniting houses
Baratheon and Stark through the union of
Robert Sun and one of Ned Stark's
daughters but only time will tell
now let's move on to our old friend
Sandor Clegane who also happens to be
traveling with Jon Snow and Daenerys
Sand doors arrival at Winterfell has
some significance because of his obvious
connection to both of the stark
daughters Arya and Sansa
some people believe in the same sand
theory which states that Sansa and
Sandor will become romantically involved
at the end of the show while others
believe that Aria and Sandor could go
travelling west of Westeros together
after everything is all said and done
either scenario has potential to be
interesting although neither of them
could happen but hey who knows if you've
seen one of my recent videos I think
there is also a chance that the Hound
could stay on as a member of Songz's
Queen's Guard assuming that both of
those characters live whatever the case
may be it will stem from this initial
reunion at the beginning of the a season
it's kind of crazy how one scene can
impact so many different characters
especially when there is so many in the
same place at the same time now I
suppose I should also mention Tyrion as
well because his reunion was Sansa could
be interesting to say the least as we
all know these two characters were once
man and wife but that ended the day that
Joffrey was murdered at his own wedding
now that so much has happened to both of
these characters since then it
should be interesting to see how they
treat each other at this stage in their
lives
I imagine that Songza will be a little
more accepting of Tyrion now knowing
that he truly was kinder than any of his
other relatives not to mention we did
hear songs expressed that when Jon
received his letter asking him to come
and greet with Daenerys Songz has said
Tyrion is nothing like the other
Lannisters so I am curious to see how
their relationship plays out in the
upcoming episodes I'm also looking
forward to the reunion between Tyrion
and bran stark as we all know Tyrion has
a soft spot for cripples bastards and
broken things which did lead to Tyrion
given bran the blueprints for having a
saddle made custom just for him this
could lead to a nice reunion with brain
and Tyrion it could even potentially
lead to them working together in some
capacity we all know that Tyrion likes
to read and he's already very
well-versed in most of Westeros is
history which could come in handy when
it's time for bran to go back inside of
the weirwood net
not to mention Samwell Tarly also has
all those books and documents
Tyrion could always help Sam look
through all that stuff to try to make
sense of it all this would also give
Tyrion another job instead of just
standing around and cracking jokes
Tyrion Lannister needs something to do
that has some sort of significance to it
he is a smart man so let's put that to
good use
Tyrion is also very clever and that
could help when it comes time to
planning the attack or defensive
strategy against the night king now
let's move on to the second reason why
the opening scene could get very
interesting I talked about some of the
biggest reunions but now I want to talk
about one other factor that could have a
very big impact on the final season as
we all know Jon is arriving at
Winterfell with Daenerys Targaryen the
very person who almost everyone in the
north was against Jon going to greet
within the first place if it wasn't bad
enough that Jon went against everyone's
wishes to go and make an alliance with
her but now Jon is bringing her right
into their backyard but Daenerys isn't
coming alone oh no no no she's also
coming with two very big-ass dragons in
a big-ass Dothraki Army who everyone
pretty much sees as savages I'm not even
sure how they're gonna feed everyone let
alone have everyone get along with one
another is a completely different story
I think it's safe to say that Jon could
catch some flack for this not just from
the other northern Lords but from Sansa
as well
sansa including the northern Lords see
the Targaryen zazz their enemies after
all it was a Targaryen that murdered
sons his grandfather and uncle and it
was also a Targaryen who sunzha believes
kidnapped and raped her aunt Lyanna now
all of this should get settled when
brain eventually reveals the truth but
when Daenerys first arrives things could
get extremely tense to say the least
according to much speculation this was
already teased in that very short clip
when we see John and Sansa reunite when
HBO uploaded that clip everyone
immediately assumed that Sansa was
staring at Daenerys Targaryen which is
very possible but she could also be
looking at Tyrion the hound
the Dothraki or even the damn dragons we
don't know who or what she's looking at
but I could definitely see someone -
having problems with Jon arriving what
company
Sansa already knows that Jon been thony
which essentially gave up his power as
king in the north but wait until
everyone finds out that Jon and Daenerys
have been sleeping together shits about
the Popoff they could damn near dedicate
the entire first episode to the opening
scene everything I have mentioned in the
video so far all stems from that seen so
many reunions so many conversations of
importance with so much at stake this
should make for one hell of an opener
now let's get out of Winterfell and head
down to King's Landing when it comes to
Cersei Lannister there isn't a whole lot
going on right now as far as we know
she's patiently waiting foryour on
Greyjoy to arrive with the golden
company and she's hoping that the army
of the Dead can defeat her enemies in
the north but this can't be all that
Cersei does at the start of the season
now since they are speeding up the show
I suppose they could have your own
arrived with the golden company almost
immediately but I'm not sure if they're
gonna do it like that since you're on
did have to go all the way to Essos and
back first Cersei is very first seen I
think one of two things could happen
according to Cersei Lannister she is
pregnant with her brother Jaime's child
assuming that's true and she is pregnant
I believe she will have a miscarriage
next season I actually believe that the
miscarriage will ultimately lead to
Cersei attempting to blow up King's
Landing but I will go more into that
when I cover the later episodes Cersei
is very first seen could be with her
waking up in a bed covered in blood not
only would that continue Cersei down the
path
making her go completely mad queen but
that would also open up the lane for
Euron Greyjoy what Jaime Lannister no
longer around and Cersei no longer
pregnant that could allow for Cersei and
Euron's relationship to let's say
blossom Cersei could potentially want to
try to get pregnant again
then Euron could finally present his big
Kraken tentacle
now if Circe's first scene doesn't
involve a miscarriage there is one other
thing we might see her do like I said
earlier I just can't picture Cersei
sitting around and waiting for
everything to fall into her lap she
would be incredibly stupid to just
completely rely on the night king
defeating Jonathan Aerys or the golden
company being enough to defend King's
Landing that will not be enough Cersei
should know this and Qyburn should know
this what that being said both of them
know what they could use to help them
defend the Iron Throne that is wildfire
in ballistas two weapons that Cersei has
added to her arsenal before I've had
this feeling that we will get a scene of
them both having those weapons
mass-produced Cersei does have good
credit with the iron bank again so
there's no reason why she should not be
able to get that done but that's just my
opinion this could have a very big
impact on the show because not only
could they potentially kill another one
of Danny's dragons but Cersei could also
blow up King's Landing that would
definitely make things a lot more
exciting in King's Landing alright but
let's move on to Filan Greyjoy because
almost all of us are expecting a big
showdown with his uncle Joran Greyjoy no
I highly doubt this what happened in the
very first episode as I said Euron is
picking up the golden company which
according to Cersei they have 20
thousand mercenaries along with
elephants trained in battle so when you
combine that with Euron's men along with
his ships there is no way in hell that
Theon can challenge his uncle in the
first episode when he's surrounded by
that many men Theon's crew is way too
small to even attempt something like
that and if they did it would be so
unrealistic it could ruin the entire
build-up the fee on completing that
Redemption arc if anything we may see
feeling arrive at the Iron Islands maybe
in hopes of finding his sister locked up
in a dungeon there or he could try to
salvage any men that may have stayed
back when everyone left fian and Euron
will have a fight to the death but I
don't think that happens until a later
episode
now let me briefly talk about Jamie's
potential scene then we can move on to
the grand finale of the first episode
I'm not a hundred percent sure that
Jamie will arrive in Winterfell in the
first episode now he absolutely could
but that all depends on where he stops
first Jamie might try to stop at
Riverrun to gather up as many men as
possible and he could also stop at the
twins if you paid attention to any of
the casting news for season 8 then you
would know that they did cast two new
actors to stand in as members of House
Frey based on that information we will
see house Frey at least one more time
Jamie could also have made plans to meet
with bran somewhere along the road even
maybe at the crossroads in who knows but
if Jamie makes a bunch of stops then he
probably won't arrive in Winterfell
until the very end of the first episode
or the beginning of the second episode
if Jaime Lannister does arrive in the
first episode I think it would be near
the very end I think the scene could
kind of play out like this do you
remember when Arya arrived back in
Winterfell last season well during that
scene we got a wide shot of Arya
overlooked on Winterfell from the
hilltop then after a few seconds we got
a close-up of arias face as she is full
of emotion from seeing her home for the
first time in so many years we could get
a similar scene with Jaime arriving as
well near the very end of the episode we
could get the exact same shot of someone
sitting on their horse overlooking
Winterfell from a distance then as the
camera changes size for the close-up we
could see that it's Jaime Lannister and
he's not alone Jaime is with Bronn and
an entire army marching behind him the
close-up could just focus on Jamie's
face for a few seconds as he
contemplates what he's about to say when
he reaches the gates that scene could
end right here before Jaime ever reaches
the game that would be a very nice
teaser for the second episode but there
is one final scene oh [ __ ] you know why
I just thought of this okay picture this
as Jaime is overlooking Winterfell and
we get to reveal that he has an army
marching behind him before the scene
ends they could do this like I said as
Jaime is overlooking Winterfell
contemplating what he's gonna say
at the same time we could see dozens or
even hundreds of birds fly out from what
their Fels gods would now that would
obviously be brain sending the birds out
for some reason but as Jaime's ever look
at Winterfell
we could see Jaime look up at the
big-ass flock of birds
wondering where the hell they're going
as Jamie looks up the camera could leave
Jamie as a tease for the next episode
but then the camera could start to
follow the birds just like when brain
sent the birds out beyond the wall
we saw them leave Winterfell then we
followed them all the way up north but
this time as we are following the birds
we can notice that they aren't traveling
that far north this time in fact they
are traveling to one of the next closest
castles like the last hearth or the car
hold as the birds are getting closer to
the castle we could hear a dragon scream
so loud that it causes all of the birds
to scatter then we get our grand finale
in the first episode the night king has
arrived at his first target chaos erupts
blue flames start scorching the castle
and everyone inside we don't even really
have to see a bunch of people die all we
need to hear are the screams coming from
inside of the castle as the blue flame
engulfs the entire area that's when
brain snaps back out of the birds but
this time brain is covered in sweat even
though he's sitting out in the snow by
the weirwood tree after brain snaps out
of it we can see him look over to John
with a terrified look on his face then
the episode cuts off in the credits roll
that would be dope but let me know what
you think keep in mind these are just
some of the big events that I think we
could see in the first episode of the
final season if you would like me to
continue and do the next episode just
leave a comment telling me to do the
next episode that way I know you want me
to and I will know that you listened
until the very end anyways I want to
thank everyone for watching the video
and I also want to thank all of my
patreon supporters I really appreciate
all the support you've shown me over the
past year it truly means a lot to me
have a great day everyone and a Happy
New Year's I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you